Speaker 1: Let's go next
to Ashton from California.
Speaker 2: It ever can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Just barely. What
kind of a device are you on?
Speaker 2: A really cheap headset.
Speaker 1: All right. OK, what's on your
mind? I'll pump up your volume here.
Speaker 2: Thanks. My question is, I know there's
a lot we can view the Ukraine and war through the
Russian invasion as a net negative, obviously.
But I was wondering, would you do you think that
you could at least concede there might be some
positive aspects to this war? And the thing that
I keep thinking about is I we hear a lot in the
news recently, especially as it relates to like
the Conservative Party in Canada. How because
of this war, there's a lot more scrutiny coming
coming, coming on to political parties
like the Conservative Party about
the kind of dark money that's funneled into them.
And the same thing could probably be said in the
United States with funding in the Republican Party
from certain Russian oligarchs and whatnot. And do
you think that may be a silver lining in this war
might be that there's more scrutiny on that now?
Speaker 1: Maybe, you know, if you said to me,
obviously, we all concede that what's happening is
terrible and there's loss of life and destruction
of all sorts of things that that we hold dear.
If you say, can you find any silver linings?
One thing that I am kind of thinking about is
we've seen the right in the United States
as well as, you know, the right in Hungary
and Brazil and other places really cozy up to
these dictatorial authoritarians like Putin
over the last five years. And one of the silver
linings of what is happening right now, I hope,
will be that there will be newfound skepticism
and kind of a return to recognizing the disaster
that these dictatorial authoritarians are so like.
If you said to me, what do I think is potentially
the best silver lining, it would be that.
Speaker 2: OK, yeah, I agree. Thank you very much.
Speaker 1: All right, thank you.
Very good call. Very good question.